Also ich habe...
Ja, also dass das ein bisschen komisch aussieht, das Bein, das habe ich schon gemerkt.
Und es fühlt sich auch...
Also die Haut ist ein bisschen anders als sonst.
Also nicht unbedingt die Farbe, aber die ist so ein bisschen schuppig.
Und was ich auch gemerkt habe, dass es manchmal so kribbelt im Unterschenkel.
Und Haarverlust? Ist Ihnen aufgefallen Haarverlust?
Das stimmt, das habe ich gemerkt, dass mir die Haare da auswirken. Ich dachte das hängt mit dem Alter zusammen.
Aber im Vergleich, auf der anderen Seite. Ich meinte das.
Ja, stimmt, das ist nicht so schlimm.
Ist Ihnen ein Atemnot oder ein Atemnotengel Gefühl aufgefallen?
Atemnot.
Also das wüsste ich nicht. Das habe ich eigentlich keine Probleme.
Also ich könnte vom... also habe ich das Gefühl weiter laufen.
Aber die Beine tun halt weh, ne?
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass meine linke Beine ein bisschen schuppig geworden sind.
Das Rechte.
Entschuldigung, das war recht. Und das Rechte war ein bisschen blass oder rötig?
Also die Farbe ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, weil mir ist halt aufgefallen, dass die Haut so schlecht ist.
Haut ist schlecht.
Haben Sie auch nachts Wadenkrampfen oder irgendwas?
Oh ja. Also manchmal habe ich nachts richtig schlechte Schmerzen.
Und das Komische ist, wenn ich dann so ein bisschen rumwander, dann geht es.
Dann wird es ein klein bisschen besser und dann kann ich mich auch wieder hinlegen.
Aber ich muss sowieso oft mal nachts zur Toilette ein bis zwei Mal gehen.
Aber deswegen habe ich eigentlich auch in der letzten Zeit nicht so gut geschlafen.
Treten diese Wadenkrampfen besonders vor allem nachts oder tagsüber?
Also tagsüber ist das nur beim Laufen.
Nur beim Laufen.
Aber in der Nacht habe ich schon auch manchmal diese Schmerzen.
Ist Ihnen ein Gefühl Verlust aufgefallen in die rechten Beine?
Was ist mir aufgefallen?
Gefühl Verlust.
Ja meinen Sie, dass ich das irgendwie so taub anfühle?
Ja, Taubheits.
Ja so ein bisschen habe ich schon den Eindruck, ich habe gesagt, es kribbelt so ein bisschen.
Und ja so ein bisschen taub ist es schon.
Aber Sie haben keine Lehmung?
Nein, ich kann das schon bewegen.
Wie ist Ihr Gangpilz? Ist das normal?
Ich sehe mich ja selber nicht.
Aber ich denke schon, dass ich vielleicht so ein klein bisschen das Bein schonle.
Sind bei Ihnen Vorerkrankungen und OP bekannt?
Na ja, also in meinem Alter wäre das ja ein Wunder, wenn ich überhaupt nichts hätte.
Ich habe seit 10 Jahren so einen Alterszucker und da nehme ich halt Metformin ein.
Und schon ewig lange habe ich hohen Blutdruck.
Wie viele Dosieren ist Metformin?
Das ist 850. Da nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
Und was war noch außer diesen Alterszucker?
Der Blutdruck ist natürlich ein bisschen zu hoch. Ja, aber das ist ja fast bei allen alten Leuten.
Aber Sie nehmen Medikamente oder nicht?
Ja, ja da nehme ich Simvastatin.
Gegen Bluthochdruck?
Ach nee, das, nee, ja warten Sie mal.
Gegen den Bluthochdruck nehme ich Simvastatin.
Ja, das andere ist für das Cholesterin, für den Cholesterinwert.
Ja, genau.
Dann nehme ich, wie heißt denn das?
Das heißt Candesatan.
Ja, wie viele Dosen Candesatan benutzt du Sie? Und seit wann?
Ja, am Anfang habe ich Ramipril genommen.
Da bin ich aber nicht gut mit klar gekommen.
Und das Candesatan, da nehme ich jetzt, das sind acht, ich meine da steht acht drauf, acht Milligramm oder Gramm oder was das ist.
Und da nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
Eine morgens und eine abends.
Und seit wann haben Sie den Bluthochdruck?
Schon lange, schon lange, 20 Jahre schon.
Entschuldigung, ich habe vergessen, ist Ihnen ein Hautausschlag aufgefallen?
Ein Hautausschlag?
Ja, so ein richtiger Hautausschlag ist das nicht.
Sondern die Haut ist halt so schuppig und sieht nicht schön aus.
Ja, okay.
Okay, haben Sie auch die Fieber?
Fieber? Ich habe mir das nicht gemessen, auf die Idee wäre ich gar nicht gekommen.
Aber Herzrasen, Herzstöpeln, Sie haben keine Herzrasen, Herzstöpeln, ja?
Nein, nein, nein. Also ich hatte vor vielen, vielen Jahren mal Herzprobleme und deswegen nehme ich auch Aspirin 100.
100? Seit wann?
Ach wie lange ist das her? Vor 15 Jahren habe ich mal so eine Stand implantiert bekommen.
Eine Stand oder zwei? Nur eine Stand implantiert?
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele da drin hocken, aber jedenfalls sind da irgendwelche Gefäße gestandet worden.
Okay, das war auch vor 15 Jahren.
Vor 15 Jahren, ja.
Würden Sie schon einmal operieren?
Ja, als Kind habe ich mal die Mandeln rausbekommen, aber das ist schon so ewig lange her.
Das ist über 70 Jahre her, keine Ahnung was damals war.
Und dann, ja, irgendwie so kleine Operationen, da war mal was am Bein operiert worden,
aber das ist schon auch alles sehr lange her.
Aber Sie haben vergessen, was war der Grund, die Spine operiert?
Ja, da hatte ich einen kleinen Unfall und da musste was genäht werden, also das war nur ein kleines Problem.
Gab es keine, die Knochenbruch oder irgendwas, ja?
Nein, nein, gebrochen war da nie was.
Nicht, ja, das war eine kleine Wundplatzwunde.
Ja, irgendwie so was, ja.
Das war auch in Art Kinderart, ja?
Ja, also als Jugendlicher, irgendwo hängen geblieben oder so, ja.
Okay, nehmen Sie auch andere Medikamente ein, außer diese Medikamente?
Nee, sonst nehme ich ja nicht nix, also gegen den Zucker, gegen die Blutfette und das Blutdruckmittel.
Sie rauchen, ja, oder?
Bitte?
Rauchen Sie ihn?
Ja, also hin und wieder rauche ich nochmal, aber eigentlich habe ich das aufgegeben.
Wann haben Sie aufgehört?
Oh, eigentlich in dem Augenblick, als ich meinen Laden aufgegeben habe.
Und zwar, ja, ich habe viele Jahre als Gastwirt gearbeitet und dann ist meine Frau gestorben.
Und dann habe ich noch ein paar Jahre weitergemacht und dann habe ich mit der Kneipe aufgehört.
Das war mir dann alleine zu anstrengend, ja.
Okay, insgesamt, wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht, ungefähr?
Oh, jetzt muss ich rechnen, wie lange habe ich geraucht.
Durchschnittlich, wie viele Zigaretten?
Ich habe eigentlich nie so furchtbar viel geraucht.
Ich habe immer nur so ein halbes Päckchen, also aus Gesellschaft eigentlich mit geraucht, ja.
Aber nie so ganz viel.
Und wie viele Jahre ungefähr?
Ja, ich bin ja schon das Knochen alt.
Also, was habe ich denn angefangen?
Ja, so mit 20 hat sich das so eingeschlichen, als ich dann auch ein bisschen Geld hatte und mir das auch leisten konnte.
Und dann habe ich bestimmt bis vor 10 Jahren habe ich geraucht, ja.
Vor 20, 30 Jahren habe ich bestimmt geraucht, ne?
Ja, gut. Ich klatüre Sie innen. Das ist eine gute Entscheidung.
Okay, das meint es, dass ungefähr 44 Jahre Sie haben geraucht und halben Päckchen.
Ja, ungefähr so.
Ungefähr 44 Jahre.
Okay. Nehmen Sie Alkohol für sich?
Ja, auch nicht mehr so viel.
Früher habe ich natürlich immer ganz gerne mal einen mitgetrunken, so in der Kneipe.
Aber ja, das habe ich eigentlich jetzt so ziemlich sein gelassen.
Hin und wieder treffe ich mich mal mit meinen Kumpels und dann trinken wir auch nochmal ein Schnäppchen.
Oder abends trinke ich auch wohl mal ein Bier, aber alleine schmeckt es eigentlich nicht so richtig.
So, ein besonderes Anlass, ja.
So kann man sagen, ja.
Was trinken Sie besonderes Anlass? Ein Bier oder irgendwas?
Ja, ein Bier oder auch mal ein paar Schnäppchen.
Bier oder Schnäppchen. Okay.
Das ist eine rhthnische Frage. Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen auch?
Drogen auch?
Drogen? Ne, also da hätten Sie mir den Laden ja gleich zugemacht.
Ne, ne, also mit Drogen habe ich nie was zu tun gehabt.
Okay.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergie und Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Alles Essen und Trinken, was ich will.
Ich habe also auch noch nie irgendwie gemerkt, dass ich auf irgendwas allergisch reagiere.
Das ist eigentlich ganz unentfändlich.
Okay, gut.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, also meine Eltern, die sind schon beide nicht alt geworden.
Mein Vater hatte sehr sehr frühen Herzinfarkt.
Deswegen, das war dann eigentlich auch so ein bisschen Anlass, dass ich nach meiner Herzgeschichte da,
dass ich dann mit dem Rauchen aufgehört habe.
Wie alt war er?
Der ist also Mitte 60 gewesen.
Also der ist wirklich nicht alt geworden.
60, ja?
Mitte 60, also ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau, 64 oder so war der.
Und Mutter seitlich?
Ja, meine Mutter, die ist zwar ein bisschen älter geworden, aber eigentlich war das auch tragisch.
Die hatte ganz was Doofes, die hatte eine Lungenembolie.
Und ist daran gestorben.
Da war sie 75 Jahre, also so alt wie ich jetzt ungefähr.
Hat sie eine chronische Erkrankung gehabt?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Möglicherweise.
Irgendwas, aber man hat uns damals gesagt, dass sie an einer Lungenembolie gestorben ist.
Ja, meine herzlichen Damen, Sie haben früh verloren, Ihre Eltern.
Na gut, meine Eltern, das ist ja schon lange her.
Haben Sie auch keine Schwestern?
Nein, ich war Einzelkind.
Ich habe den Laden von den Eltern übernommen.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Verwidwet, verwidwet, ne?
Sie haben verwidwet, ja genau, verwidwet.
Sie haben schon erzählt, Entschuldigung.
Sind Sie wahrscheinlich Verhältner? Was haben Sie gemacht früher?
Ja, ich war Gastwirt.
Ich habe eine Kneipe gehabt, so lokal, wo man sich getroffen hat.
Wo man Bier getrunken hat und geraucht hat und Schnaps getrunken hat.
Und Feste gefeiert und wo die Männer abends nach Feierabend sich getroffen haben oder so.
Oder zum Kartenspielen.
Haben Sie ein Kind?
Nein, wir waren kinderlos.
Kinderlos.
Waren Sie im letzten sechs Monate im Ausland?
Im Ausland? Ne, das kann ich mir gar nicht erlauben.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, also diese Corona-Impfung seinerzeit, die habe ich natürlich alle tapfer machen lassen.
Das hat man ja gesagt, alte Leute sollten das tun.
Und ja, ich gehe auch, wenn ich daran denke und wenn es gerade so passt, gehe ich auch zur Grippeimpfung hin.
Ja, aber sonst wüsste ich nicht, wann ich zuerst geimpft worden bin.
Ich habe einige Fragen vergessen.
Haben Sie morgen Steifigkeit oder irgendwas?
Wer soll steif sein?
Morgen Steifigkeit.
Was sagt das?
Ich meine Anlassschmerzen.
Wenn Sie von dem Bett aufgestanden sind, haben Sie auch Anlassschmerzen oder Morgensteifigkeit oder Rückenschmerzen?
Ja, mein Rücken tut mir tatsächlich immer weh, weil ich früher so viel gestanden bin.
Oder Fingerschmerzen?
Also, so müde Knochen habe ich schon immer. Aber solche Schmerzen wie jetzt mit dem Bein habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Treiben Sie nicht regelmäßig Sport?
So sehe ich glaube ich wirklich nicht aus. Nein, also das habe ich nie gerne gemacht, Sport.
Als Jugendlicher vielleicht mal so ein bisschen, aber was man so in der Schule machen musste, da hat man auch mal Fußball gespielt.
Aber dass ich jetzt ein großer Sportler wäre, kann ich wirklich nicht sagen.
In Leszys eine Woche hatten Sie eine Fernreise gemacht? Ich meinte eine Bus- oder Flug-Fernreise?
Nein, ich habe keine langen Reisen, ich war immer nur zu Hause. Ich habe einen Hund und da kann ich gar nicht so viel weg wissen.
Danke Herr Schneider. Meinerseits habe ich alle wichtige Fragen gestellt. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich will jetzt natürlich wissen, woher die Schmerzen kommen und was man dagegen machen kann. Das hoffe ich ja, dass Sie mir helfen können.
Ja eigentlich meinerseits habe ich einige verdacht, aber ich kann nicht genau sagen. Wahrscheinlich haben Sie eine Schaufensterkrankheit.
Das klingt ja interessant.
Das ist eine langsame aufgetretene Krankheit. Es geht immer langsamer und schlechter und schlimmer.
Einige Sachen, wie Sie sagen, dass die Hautfarbänderungen, das Halferlust oder Krippelgefühl, bestätigt diese Krankheit.
Im Medizinischen Bereich sagen wir, dass es eine Schmerzkrankheit ist. Wir müssen sofort Ihren Puls prüfen.
Wie war das, Ihren Puls? Ich meinte das ist ein Beinpuls. Und sofort die Ultraschall, die Doppler-Ultraschall.
Tut das weh?
Nein, Ultraschall ist komplett schmerzfrei für eine Methode. Und es dauert in den maximal 3 oder 5 Minuten.
Das geht so schnell, das ist ja gut.
Das ist schon ein bisschen schmerzfrei. Sie machen alles hier. Sie warten nicht so lange. Ich werde alles, ich werde auch Blut abnehmen von Ihnen.
Und ich werde auch diese Doppler-Ultraschall führen. Und Sie werden nicht so weit hier bleiben.
Ich muss nicht lange da bleiben.
Das ist ja schon mal gut. Ich muss ja auch wieder zurück zu meinem Hund. Der ist wach.
Genau. Sie vermissen sich.
Ok. Möchte ich jemand von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch irgendwelche Fragen stellen?
Welches Bein wurde operiert, rechts oder links?
Das ist so lange her. Das war eine kleine Fleischrunde. Das war am linken Bein.
Also strahlen Ihre Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Wo die Schmerzen ausstrahlen?
Ja.
Eigentlich sind die überwiegend im Unterschenkel. Aber in den letzten Tagen haben sie bis in den Oberschenkel gereicht.
Also gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt auslaufen? Hochlagerung?
Ja. Wie gesagt, stehen bleiben, stehen bleiben hilft.
In der Nacht ist es so, dass ich, wenn die Schmerzen zu arg sind, dass ich dann tatsächlich mich hinsetzen muss und ein bisschen aufstehen und hin und herlaufen.
Und dann geht es auch wieder besser.
Haben Sie etwas dagegen eingenommen bis lang?
Nein, ich habe mich nicht getraut, noch mehr Schmerzenmittel zu nehmen. Ich nehme ja sowieso das Aspirin 100. Ich weiß, dass es gegen Schmerzen nicht so viel ist.
Aber da soll man ja auch nicht so viel davon nehmen. Deswegen habe ich jetzt nichts weiter genommen.
Darf ich fragen?
Natürlich.
Haben Sie Herzraten, Herzklopfen?
Also mein Herz klopft eigentlich inzwischen ganz normal. Hat der Kollege aber auch gefragt.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Hat er auch gefragt, habe ich auch verneint. Also ich habe mich nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich nicht fiebrig.
Ja, danke.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Darf ich mal eine neue Patientin vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich. Wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Ja, genau. Friedrich Schneider ist 74 Jahre alt, 1 Meter, 76 groß, wiegt aktuell 89 Kilogramm.
Er stellt sich mit seit einem Jahr bestehende, prognetende Schmerzen im rechten Bein vor.
Okay.
Mir ist das habe ich geschrieben.
Okay. Normalerweise hat er Schmerzen seit einem Jahr, aber trotzdem hat er eine heftige Schmerzen beim letzten Mal nach dem 1 Meter Laufen.
Nach einem Meter?
100 Meter, Entschuldigung.
Er brauchte Pause machen.
Er muss Pause machen, ja?
Ja, er brauchte Pause machen. Er leidet unter, war der Krampf vor allem beim Laufen, auch nachts.
Schmerzen war früher Oberschenkel und gerade ist der Unterschenkel auf Strahl.
Der Schmerzintensität liegt auf einer Schmerzskala bei 7 von 10.
Der rechte Beinhaut ist schupig geworden.
Die Haut des rechten Beines.
Ja, genau. Die Haut des rechten Beines.
Die Haut des rechten Beines ist schupig geworden.
Haarverlust auch berichtet.
Und er klagte über auch Parasthesie und Haarverlust.
Und die Frage nach Tachikardie, Dyspneu, Hypoesthesie, Fieber und Ödema und Fieber wurden verleint.
Als Vorerkrankungen berichtet, seit 10 Jahren leidet er an Diabetik, behandelt mit Metformin 850 mg.
Seit 10 Jahren leidet er an Diabetik, behandelt mit Metformin 850 mg.
Früher behandelt mit Ramipirir, aber Ramipirir abgesetzt.
Er behandelt weiter mit Candesartan 8 mg.
Einmal morgen und einmal abends.
Er leidet auch an Hyperkolesthylermin, behandelt mit Zynvastatin.
Die Dosierung habe ich vergessen.
Bei mir ist die Dosierung unbekannt. Entschuldigung.
Ja, vergessen. Ich werde nochmal nachfragen.
Vor 5 Jahren musste eine Implantate operieren.
Entschuldigung. Vor 15 Jahren eine Implantate.
Wo?
Seitdem benötigt er ein Assetisystem. Entschuldigung.
Wo wurde eine Implantate implantiert?
Es muss ein Herz sein. Entschuldigung.
Ja.
Aber ich habe...ja genau. Sie sind recht.
Das war Beinode. Ja. Richtig Frage.
Anfangs dachte ich, dass es ein Herz im Ständen.
Ja.
Okay. Er behandelt mit ASS 100 mg.
Als Kindheit Translektome.
In der Kindheit oder als Kind?
Als Kind. Okay.
Als Kind oder in der Kindheit? Eins von beiden.
Okay. In der Kindheit.
In der Kindheit wurde Translektome durchgeführt.
Und auch wegen einem Unfall, einer kleinen Platzwunde, musste er einfach nähen.
Genäht werden. Musste genäht werden.
Noch zum einem Messe seit 10 Jahren hat das Rauchen aufgehört.
Aber insgesamt 22 Jahre.
Es besteht ein Rauchen im Messe. Entschuldigung.
Es besteht ein Rauchen im Messe.
22 Jahre alt.
22 Packungsjahre.
22 Packungsjahre. Entschuldigung.
22 Packungsjahre hat vor 10 Jahren aufgehört.
Okay.
Alkoholkonsum.
Nur bei einem besonderen Anleitung.
1 oder 2.
4 verneint.
Allergieunfertigung wurde verneint.
Vater ist an Neukartinfarkt.
Entschuldigung.
Verstorben.
Mutter ist 75 Jahre alt.
Er ist Einzelkind.
Er ist verwitwet.
Er ist aktuell Rentner.
Hat kein Kind.
Keine Kinder.
Reise an dem Messe unaufwendig.
Impfung ist vollständig.
Und das war alles.
Entschuldigung.
Ich musste fragen.
Sie hat erkannt, dass es stimmt.
Aber ich musste fragen, wo war das Ständ?
Das war Ständ auch Gehirnsein an Interventionen, Radiologen.
Aber anfangs dachte ich, dass es nur Herz...
Das ist auch richtig.
Hat er auch gesagt.
Er hat gesagt, er hatte Herzprobleme.
Genau.
Und da ist er mit dem Ständ versorgt worden.
Da haben sie noch gefragt.
Eine oder zwei Ständs.
Und da hat er gesagt, keine Ahnung, was sie da gemacht haben.
Aber seitdem geht es mir wieder besser.
Das ist ein Ständ.
Okay.
Genau.
Aufgrund dieser anämestischen Angabe und geschilderten Beschwerden habe ich den Verdacht auf eine POVK.
Was könnte differenzial diagnostisch noch sein?
TvT kann sein.
Einige Arteritis, großartige Kawa Saki oder einige Arteritis kann sein.
Okay.
Und was kann noch sein?
Was kann noch sein?
Haben Sie noch eine Idee?
Sie haben nach morgen gefragt.
Ich habe noch gefragt, diese Leimgeschichte, eine Wander oder irgendwas.
Sie wurden gefragt.
Was haben Sie gefragt?
Ich meine jetzt Lümer, Leimer, diese.
Sie waren im Ausland nicht.
Ach so, okay.
Sie waren unauffällig.
Genau.
Aus diesem Grund.
Ach so, Leinborreliose, meint Sie.
Ja, Leinborreliose, ich meinte das.
Okay.
Aber Sie haben noch was anderes gefragt.
Sie haben nach morgen gefragt.
Ja, ich habe noch gefragt, ob es eine Rheumatologie gibt.
Genau.
Also das wäre unter Umständen noch so eine Idee, dass der rheumatologische ein Problem hätte.
Rheumatologie und auch die Arteritis oder auch diese Immunkrankheit.
Ja, gut.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit dem Patienten?
Ich muss die Diagnostik sofort kontrollieren.
Dorsalispedispuls oder Femoralpuls oder popliteal Arteris.
ADP und ATP.
Tibialis popteria und Dorsalis.
Tibialis popteria.
Und nur an den Beinen?
Nein, nur an beiden Beinen. Ich muss auch die Messer und die tropischen Zeichen vergleichen.
Tropische Zeichen.
Ja, tropische Zeichen. Ich meinte, dass sie Haarverlust oder Schubpinkie hat.
Friedrich ist ein Mann.
Entschuldigung, er hat eine Schubpikie Haut.
Natürlich das Wichtigste ist die Dopplestornographie.
Ja, was machen Sie noch?
Was mache ich noch? Sie meinen das mitgebende Verfahren oder Labor?
Erstmal Labor. Und vielleicht noch körperliche Untersuchung. Was könnte sein, was Sie noch?
Körperliche Untersuchung, Hommance Zeichen oder andere Zeichen.
Also zum TVT-Auschluss.
TVT, Hommance Zeichen.
Was wäre auch vielleicht noch interessant? Er hat ja von Kribbelparazisien gesprochen.
Ich muss auch diese neurologische Zähnereflexe überprüfen.
Neurologische Kontrolle auf alle Fälle.
Ja, und dann sind wir schon beim Labor. Was würden Sie bestimmen?
Ja, der Dämmer ist wichtig.
Auf alle Fälle, ja, genau. Was ist noch wichtig?
Procalcitonik kann sein. ProBNP kann sein.
Auch die Rechhärzeinstellung oder irgendwas.
Was war noch? Auch die Endzündungsparameter oder Nierenparameter.
Natürlich auch die Lebeparameter.
Endzündungparameter, ja.
Gut, dann haben wir die Duplexsonographie.
Haben Sie schon gesagt. Und was erwarten Sie bei der Duplexsonographie?
Verenglückte Gefäße und verminderte Ströme.
Es muss 2B sein, oder 3?
Entschuldigung, es muss 3 sein.
Was ist 3? Was meinen Sie?
Ich meinte, dass es per VK steht.
VK-Stadium 3?
3, ja. Nein, 3 nicht. Entschuldigung.
Ich meinte eher, auf welcher Etage vermuten Sie den Verschluss?
Ah, am Ende. Es ist 3. Es muss 2B sein.
Ich habe vergessen eigentlich.
Nein, das ist ja das Stadium.
Per VK-Stadium. Sprechen wir gleich darüber.
Jetzt wollte ich wissen. Sie haben gesagt, Sie machen die Duplexsonographie.
Und da habe ich gesagt, was erwarten Sie? Sie erwarten eine Verengung oder einen Verschluss?
Genau.
Auf welcher Ebene erwarten Sie den denn? Oberschenkelebene oder Unterschenkelebene?
Genau, es ist richtig geschrieben. Oberschenkel.
Nein, Unterschenkel.
Er beschreibt eine Claudicatio im Unterschenkel.
Das ist jetzt akut. Aber nach oben gehen.
Möglicherweise hat er schon latent immer eine Verengung gehabt in der Unterschenkelebene.
Und möglicherweise jetzt einen akuten Verschluss im Oberschenkel.
Davon gucken.
Aber das Stadium ist B2 oder 2B?
2B.
Ja, lassen Sie uns gucken. Was ist Stadium 1?
Stadium 1 ist keine Beschwerden.
Keine Beschwerden? Stadium 2?
Keine Beschwerden. Nach dem langen Reisen kann es langsam passieren.
Oder nicht häufig.
Stadium 2A ist mehr als 100 Meter.
Ich meine sogar mehr als 200 Meter.
Entschuldigung, 200 Meter.
Und dann kommen wir zum Stadium 2B.
2B ist 200 Meter.
Wenn es weniger ist, genau.
Was ist denn PHAVK Stadium 3?
Das ist die Ülliserose oder Totalverschluss.
Beschwerden, Ruhe.
Ruhe Schmerz, genau.
Und Stadium 4?
Spontan Wund oder irgendwas.
Das ist Stadium 4.
Stadium 4 ist nekrosen Wunden, offene Stellen, Pieperpup.
Entschuldigung, ich habe ein Durcheinander.
Heute ist einiges durcheinander, würde ich mal sagen.
Wir spielen jetzt unsere Anamnesen schnell noch zu Ende.
Ich bin gespannt, was Sie für Ergebnisse rausbekommen.
Vor allen Dingen erstmal, was die Fußpulse bringen.
Da kann man ja noch eine bestimmte Sache machen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Ihnen das was sagt.
Knöchelarmindex.
Das hat gleich Blutdruck an den Knöcheln und Blutdruck am Arm.
Ob da eine große Differenz ist.
Gut, das wäre vielleicht noch so was, was man bestimmen könnte.
Dann natürlich muss man gucken, was die PHAVP-Honographie gibt.
Was Sie da sehen.
Was wäre denn das nächste bildgebende Verfahren?
Angiografie.
Genau, die Angiografie.
Gut, das werden wir ja nicht heute und nicht morgen machen.
Sondern jetzt gucken wir erstmal nach den Befunden von heute.
Dann können wir uns nachher den Patienten nochmal zusammen angucken.
Gut, Herr Dr. Toprak. Heute ging es ein bisschen durcheinander sprachlich.
Wir haben immer noch das Z, was Ihnen große Schwierigkeiten macht.
Und was manchmal wirklich mich rätseln lässt, wovon Sie sprechen.
Und Sie verwaschen die Sprache so ein bisschen.
Das führt dazu, dass man sie manchmal nicht gut verstehen kann.
Und dann machen Sie manchmal auch witzige Wortkonstruktionen.
Ich habe verstanden, als Sie nach den Anlaufschmerzen gefragt haben, habe ich Anlassschmerzen gehört.
Deswegen habe ich nochmal nachgefragt, was Sie meinen.
Ich glaube, Sie meinten den Anlaufschmerz morgens.
Das kennt aber der Patient nicht. Der kennt den Begriff nicht.
Also es heißt Anlaufschmerz und nicht Anlassschmerz.
Ein Anlass ist eine Begebenheit, ein Grund, weshalb man irgendwo hingeht.
Der Anlass für meinen Arztbesuch ist, dass ich Schmerzen habe.
Es heißt Anlaufschmerz.
Aber Sie müssen den Patienten natürlich fragen, wenn Sie morgens aufstehen,
haben Sie dann das Gefühl, dass die Beine noch gar nicht so richtig wollen,
dass Ihnen die Gelenke steif sind.
Wenn Sie nach Morgensteifigkeit fragen, dann kann der vielleicht ganz andere Ideen haben.
Das war das eine.
Dann haben Sie im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch ein komisches Wort verwendet für die Progredienz.
Sie wollten glaube ich sagen Progrediente Schmerzen, aber Sie haben irgendwas anderes gesagt.
Sie haben Progrente oder so gesagt.
Also Progrediente.
Also Voranschreiten aus dem Lateinischen.
Dann ist noch mal die Frage, wo hat der Patient seine Schmerzen geschildert?
Wo tut es ihm weh?
Genau. Wir haben vergessen.
Sie haben aber was gesagt.
Am Anfang hat er gesagt, der rechte Unterschenkel.
Der hat ihm die ganze Zeit weh getan.
Und jetzt seit drei Tagen, wo das sich verschlechtert hat, tut ihm auch der Oberschenkel weh.
Und im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch haben Sie genau das Gegenteil gesagt.
Da haben Sie gesagt, ihm tut früher der Oberschenkel weh und jetzt der Unterschenkel.
Also Vorsicht.
Dann, ja, das wäre eigentlich ein Begriff, der unbedingt kommen muss.
Wie nennt man denn solche Art von Schmerzen?
Welche Art?
Diese Schmerzen, die kommen und die sich wieder zurückbilden, wenn man in Ruhe ist.
Wie heißt der Begriff?
Könnten Sie ihn nochmal detaillieren? Ich konnte es nicht verstehen.
Wie nennt man diese Schmerzsymptomatik, wenn jemand merkt, dass er nicht mehr weiterlaufen kann, stehen bleiben muss und nachher wieder weitergehen kann?
Ah, la decassion intermittent, das ist die Meinung.
Ja, das wäre ein Stichwort, das im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch unbedingt fallen müsste.
Also der Patient stellt sich vor mit progrienten Schmerzen und er beschreibt eine klassische Claude-de-patsio-intermittent.
Das müsste zwingend kommen.
Dann, ja, wieder und wieder und wieder immer das Gleiche.
Wahrscheinlich haben Sie ein Problem mit Ihren Beingefäßen.
Aber nicht wahrscheinlich Sie haben.
Und auch als Vorerkrankung er berichtet.
Nee, als Vorerkrankung berichtet er von.
Ich habe es mir heute extra aufgeschrieben.
Denken Sie daran, das Verb steht an zweiter Stelle.
Das ist einfach so im Deutschen.
Und wenn es da nicht steht, klingt es nicht richtig.
Man kann das mal verkehrt machen, aber nicht ständig.
Dann haben Sie wieder, eigentlich völlig ohne Einleitung, diese Familienanamnese erwähnt.
Sowohl bei den Fragen als auch beim Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch haben Sie eigentlich gesagt,
das und das sind seine Beschwerden.
Der Vater ist mit 65 am Herzen erfahrt gestorben, die Mutter mit 75 an der Lungenembolie.
Also die Familienanamnese des Patienten ergab, dass der Vater und die Mutter pfiffen.
Dann haben wir das.
Der Mensch ist selber 74 Jahre alt.
Er erzählt, dass die Eltern mit 75 und 65 gestorben sind.
Das liegt also mindestens 25 bis 30 Jahre zurück.
Da ist es eigentlich nicht mehr angebracht, sein Beileid auszusprechen.
Das macht man nicht.
Wenn jemand sagt, meine Frau ist letzte Woche gestorben,
dann kann ich sagen, mein herzliches Beileid.
Aber ein so lang zurückliegender, auch in der Natur der Sache liegender Todesfall.
Mir kondoliert doch heute niemand mehr, weil meine Mutter vor 15 Jahren gestorben ist.
Das macht man einfach nicht.
Es ist ja zu erwarten, wenn ich selber über 70 bin, dass meine Mutter nicht immer noch lebt.
Das ist einfach so, das liegt in der Natur der Dinge.
Alte Leute sterben irgendwann.
Wenn ich jetzt sage, oh je, oh je, wie gesagt, mein Ehepartner ist vor wenigen Monaten verstorben,
das ist eine andere Geschichte, oder mein Bruder oder meine Schwester.
Das ist ja näher dran.
Aber wenn man bei einem alten Menschen das lange zurücklegt, würde ich nie kondolieren, würde ich nie sagen.
Was habe ich noch?
Ja, wichtig ist tatsächlich, beide Beine angucken, Fußpose, Seitenvergleich nicht vergessen.
Auch die tropischen Veränderungen, das haben Sie schön gesagt, tropische Störungen, die hat er ja geschildert.
Tüm tüm tüm tüm.
Gut, ja, Noxen haben wir gehabt.
Was man tatsächlich auch mal so einfließen lassen kann,
das ist, wenn man auf ausdrückliche Nachfrage, hat der Patient den aktuelle Herzbeschwerden vernachlässigt, verneint.
Also dass man sagt, ich habe danach gefragt, aber er hat gesagt, da hat er im Augenblick keine Beschwerden.
Das ist schon, das ist schon auch so ein bisschen verbindlich dann.
Und Sie haben glaube ich auch nicht so richtig verstanden, was der vom Beruf gemacht hat. Sie haben nicht so richtig gefragt danach.
Er hatte eine Kneipe.
Er hatte eine Kneipe, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, wissen Sie, was eine Kneipe ist?
Eine Kneipe ist eine Restaurant, eine kleine Restaurant.
Ein Lokal, ja, genau.
Sie verkaufen Alkohol oder irgendwas, ja?
Und irgendwas, ja, genau.
Aber überwiegend Alkohol tatsächlich.
Ja, überwiegend Alkohol.
Ja, also und ja, insofern ist er in diesem Dunstkreis praktisch ja alt geworden.
Aber man kann nicht sagen, er ist Rentner.
Ja, aber das ist schon wichtig, dass er früher als Gastwirt gearbeitet hat.
Gastwirt. Gastwirt.
Ja, ich konnte das Worte nicht verstehen. Gastwirt.
Ah, ja. Gastronomie, das ist die Oberbranche.
Gastwirt, ah, Menschschaft.
Gastwirt, ja.
Ja, also ich denke mal, wir hatten immer noch Probleme mit ihrer Aussprache.
Dass sie, man muss sehr, sehr gut hinhören.
Man muss sehr, sehr gut hinhören, weil sie nicht besonders präzise artikulieren.
Sie verwaschen die Wörter so ein bisschen.
Ich kann das nicht nachmachen.
Es wäre eine schlechte Imitation.
Ich kann das nicht gut machen.
Aber hören Sie vielleicht noch mal rein in die Aufnahme, dass Sie merken, dass Sie, ja,
ich glaube, in der deutschen Sprache gibt es ziemlich viel so harte Laute.
Das hört man alles nicht.
Sie machen das alles weich.
Und ich glaube aber, im Türkischen gibt es auch viele.
Also hart anklingende Laute gibt es doch durchaus.
Das ist doch eigentlich keine so weiche Sprache, sondern da gibt es das doch durchaus.
Und das hört man eben oft bei Ihnen nicht raus.
Es ist alles so, ja, es ist ein bisschen verwaschen.
Und damit ist es schwierig, sie immer zu verstehen und immer das Richtige rauszuhören.
Wenn es ganz schlimm war, habe ich nachgefragt.
Ja, und ich habe auch hin und wieder ja gleich gesagt, wenn irgendeine grammatikalische Geschichte gar nicht stimmte.
Gut, irgendwie bin ich heute Abend nicht so richtig zufrieden. Merken Sie, ne?
Ja, ich auch.
Weil wir es schon so oft gemacht haben.
Und ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass wir so richtig einen Fortschritt erreichen.
Sondern es ist eigentlich immer wieder dasselbe.
Daselbe ist falsch.
Immer wieder dieselben Fehler.
Und ich weiß nicht, was wir dagegen tun können.
Ja, eigentlich finde ich fändlich ist schade, wenn Sie zur Prüfung antreten und die sagen Ihnen,
lieber Doktor, wir verstehen Sie nicht. Das wäre doof.
Ja, also müssen wir was dran tun, dass man Sie besser verstehen kann.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie eine Möglichkeit haben, sprechen Sie auf Ihr Handy und hören Sie es nachher ab.
Machen Sie eine Sprachnachricht auf Deutsch. Natürlich nicht auf Türkisch.
Machen Sie eine Sprachnachricht an sich selber und hören Sie sie nachher ab.
Und registrieren Sie mal, wie ausgeprägt die Artikulation ist.
Oder hören Sie unsere Simulation an. Sie müssten eigentlich raushören, dass es da einen Unterschied gibt.
Bei mir knallt das viel mehr. Ich mache ein scharfes Tö, ich mache ein scharfes Kö.
Und bei Ihnen ist alles ein bisschen abgeschwächt.
Man kann deshalb oftmals nicht genau verstehen, was Sie sagen.
Und dazu kommt, dass Sie eben tatsächlich von dieser Satzstellung her oftmals auch noch Fehler machen
und ein paar Grammatikfehler schleichen sich ein. Aber alles zusammen ist ein bisschen viel.
Entweder schlechte Aussprache und alles andere richtig oder gute Aussprache.
Dann darf auch mal ein Fehler darin sein. Aber alles drei zusammen ist ein bisschen viel.
Gut. Und versuchen wir nochmal Ihr Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch schön zu strukturieren.
Dass Sie wirklich im Geist die Überschriften setzen.
Bei der Frage nach der Familienanamnese hat der Patient das und das gesagt.
Und die Frage nach Vorerkrankungen ergab einen langjährigen Diabetes-Melitis Typ 2 seit zehn Jahren.
Ach, da stimmt auch irgendwas nicht. Sie haben, glaube ich, gesagt, der hohe Blutdruck seit zehn Jahren.
Da hat er aber gesagt seit 20 Jahren und der Diabetes seit zehn Jahren.
Also dass man das ein bisschen mehr anmoderiert.
Dass man nicht einfach nur die Fakten untereinander stellt, sondern sagt, jetzt berichte ich über dieses Thema, jetzt berichte ich über dieses Thema.
Auch beim Patienten würde ich auch sagen, also erstmal eigentlich ja schön, dass Sie da...
Ich habe ein paar Fragen zu Ihren persönlichen Daten. Die muss ich mal eben abfragen.
Und dann, was sind Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden? Und dann kommen natürlich die Nachfragen.
Die Nachfragen zu den aktuellen Beschwerden.
Und dann kann man vielleicht auch so ein bisschen moderieren, sagen, Ihren allgemeinen Gesundheits- oder um Ihre Beschwerden richtig einzuschätzen, muss ich noch ein paar andere Fragen stellen.
Dann fragt man zum Beispiel nach Herzbeschwerden, Verdauung. Ja, haben Sie nicht gefragt, ne?
Verdauung und Wasserlassen haben Sie nicht gefragt?
Da gab es eine Besuchlich mit Wasserlassen oder...
Er hat gesagt, dass er nachts auf die Toilette muss, ne?
Gibt es eine Besuchlich mit dieser Krankheit mit Verdauungproblemen?
Nein, aber das müssen Sie trotzdem immer fragen. Das ist ja das Schlimme.
Sie müssen ja diese ganzen anderen Schwachsinnfragen auch stellen.
Das Herzputt in der Gutjahrherz und Gefäße hängt natürlich zusammen, klar.
Aber Sie müssen ja diese ganzen Rahmenfragen, die in Ihrem Kataloge drin sind, die müssen Sie ja trotzdem stellen.
Und dann muss man das halt ein bisschen mehr klär sagen. Der guten Ordnung halber muss ich auch noch danach fragen.
So. Und auch das ist so was, Sie haben jetzt zum Beispiel im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch nicht erwähnt, schmerzbedingte Insomnie.
Ja, dass der also nachts aufwacht, weil sein Bein nicht gut durchblutet ist und wenn er dann rumläuft, wird es wieder besser.
Das hat er Ihnen erzählt, aber das ist unter den Tisch gefallen.
Gut, also nochmal ein bisschen Struktur in Ihren Fragebogen, ein bisschen eine Anmoderation.
Jetzt kommt ein neues Thema. Jetzt habe ich über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden gefragt.
Jetzt frage ich noch nach Ihren Vorerkrankungen. Ist bei Ihnen was bekannt? Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Wie ist denn generell Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten? Da frage ich dann nach den Noxen.
Da kann man dann auch fragen, treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Gut, das gehört eigentlich, finde ich auch immer ganz gut so zu den Lebensgewohnheiten dazu.
Dann kommt natürlich so die Frage nach dem Umfeld. Sie werden sich vielleicht wundern, aber das ist für uns auch wichtig.
Die Frage, ob es in Ihrer Familie irgendwelche Krankheiten gab.
Ihre Eltern leben vermutlich nicht mehr, kann ich schon bei jemandem mit 74 sagen.
Waren da irgendwelche Erkrankungen bekannt? Man kann das ein bisschen verpacken.
Damit es nicht so abrupt ist. Und praktisch die entsprechenden Überleitungen können Sie dann als Arztgespräche verwenden.
Natürlich wissen die Kollegen, was sie alles abgefragt haben und worüber sie berichten werden.
Sie müssen da also nicht so weit ausholen. Aber immerhin kann man schon sagen, in der Familienanamnese ergab sich
oder bei der vegetativen Anamnese ergab der Patient eine schmerzbedingte Insomnie.
Insbesondere in den letzten Wochen. Ansonsten aber Nuketorie ein bis zwei Mal.
Auch das raubt ihm ein bisschen den Schlaf. Also ein bisschen mehr Moderation.
Damit das ein bisschen verbindlicher wird. Gut, nehmen Sie bitte nicht krumm.
Es ist gut gemeint, ich möchte nicht, dass Sie in der Prüfung sitzen und dass Sie sie blöde angucken und sagen,
Nö, das wollen wir so nicht. Aber arbeiten Sie daran, ich möchte, dass Sie Ihre Prüfung bestehen.
Ich möchte, dass alle Ihre Prüfung bestehen. Wir brauchen türkische Ärzte. Wir brauchen sie alle.
Es gibt jetzt einen neuen Trend. Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie das gehört haben.
Ich habe eine große Überraschung. Herr Lindemann ist jetzt unser neuer Gesundheitsminister.
Er hat eine Initiative ergriffen, dass die Dokumente von medizinischen Fachkräften besser oder schneller anerkannt werden.
Vielleicht hilft es ja für Sie alle, dass die Bürokratie in diesem Hinblick ein bisschen abgespeckt wird.
Und dass Sie ein bisschen schneller zu Ihren Approbationen kommen. Sprachkenntnisse sind aber das A und O.
Das wissen Sie alle. Wenn Sie sich nicht mit Ihren Patienten und Ihren Kollegen einschlägig unterhalten können, können Sie nicht gut arbeiten.
Egal ob mündlich oder schriftlich, heute wird alles dokumentiert. Sie müssen alles irgendwo in den Computer schreiben.
Ich gebe zu, ich habe im Laufe meiner Tätigkeit im Krankenhaus verheerende Kommentare im Computer gelesen,
wo man sagt, was um Gottes Willen hat der Mensch gemeint? Was wollte er uns mit diesem Satz sagen?
Weil die Leute einfach nicht gut Deutsch sprechen. Es ist das A und O, dass sie angemessen dokumentieren können,
dass sie angemessen kommunizieren können, sowohl mit Fachleuten als auch mit den Patienten. A und O. Die Patienten, das ist Ihre Kundschaft.
Und die müssen Sie verstehen und Sie müssen selber auch verstehen, was die von Ihnen wollen.
Gut, in diesem Sinne. Wie gesagt, nehmen Sie es mir bitte nicht übel.
Wir sehen uns sehr gerne am nächsten Donnerstag. Einen Fall habe ich noch mit.
Gott sei Dank, ich bin nicht übel.
Gut, halten Sie sich die Ohren steif. Es kann nur besser werden.
Vielen Dank.
Einen schönen Abend für heute. Wir sehen uns sehr gerne übermorgen. Ich hoffe, dass nichts dazwischen kommt.
Ich bin mit den beiden großen Kindern alleine am Donnerstagabend. Ich hoffe aber sehr, dass am 9 Uhr beide schlafen.
Wenn es ganz dicke kommt, muss ich zwischendurch mal kurz verschwinden. Aber ich hoffe, dass das nicht passieren wird.
Und ansonsten habe ich hier dann zwei kleine blonde Mädchen sitzen, die mitmachen.
Okay, also für heute einen schönen Abend. Danke allen fürs Mitmachen, fürs Mitdenken.
Und wir sehen uns am Donnerstag. Tschüss.
Tschüss, vielen Dank.